[Music]  when we were in Hogwarts everything was  different at that time he's seen the  student like any other  [Applause]  I thought I knew told I was wrong  [Music]  sniffing Oh bear talk to breakfast soon  into seven pieces  there is some good in tom no he has  always been moldable Tom Marvolo riddle  after graduating from Hogwarts quit his  job at borgin and Burkes and  mysteriously disappears 1943 the year of  the scandal house-elf  murders her own mistress hepzibah's  smith descendant of the ancient  Hufflepuff family death by poisoning  cold case and yet i'm still smelling  dark magic here  I promised Tom I Grisha McLaggen heir of  Gryffindor we'll stop you  [Music]  you